de nos systèmes alimentaires
mond
une spécialisation
sur principalement
et des échanges commerciaux
très importants.
des aliments sont transportés
d'une partie de la planète
ces systèmes de transport
sont mis en difficulté à cause
eu des conséquences
très importantes pour
et ça a aussi fortement augmenté
les prix, ce qui a eu un impact
les plus pauvres, et augmentant
de façon significative la faim
- Et donc, on se rend compte
que ce n'est peut-être pas
qu'il manque. Il y aurait assez
de nourriture pour tout
l'accessibilité?
- Absolument. Il faut savoir
de l'alimentation des produits
alimentaires qui sont produits
et ne sont jamais utilisés
Et puis une grande partie
biocarburant. Et égaleme
des grandes surfaces sontsssssss
qui ne sont pas vivris,s,s, et
donc... L'accent a été mis plusn
plutôt que la... defofofocaliser
sur la production d'aliments'e't
un des grands lllèmes
qui a montré la fragilitéèèèèèèe
actuel.
- Oui, j'aimerais bien,riririris
me don d d des exemples
parce qu'en effet, il y a q q qs
des atatations de grande
vulnérabilité parce qu'ils n'ont
rmrmrmais un peu sur toutes
les lèvres, ils n'ont pas f f f.
- Exactement. Beaucoup
de politiques nationales
sont une continuation encore
des politiques coloniales
et post-coloniales où l'accent
a été mis sur la production
dans les pays en voie de
développement sur des cultures
de rente telles que le coton,
le cacao, le café ou le palmier
à huile. Et de ce fait,
la grande production n'était pas
destinée aux populations locales
mais à l'exportation. Et donc,
ces pays-là sont des grands
importateurs de nourriture.
Et lorsque les marchés
internationaux sont
en difficulté, ce sont
les premiers à souffrir.
Et donc, ils n'ont pas
cette souveraineté alimentaire
Et on voit maintenant que des
pays comme la France, avec la
crise du COVID, parle égal
de souveraineté alimentaire,
même au niveau de la France.
Et donc, ça montre vraim
que les systèmes alimentaires
actuels ont besoin d'être
repensés en profondeur
- Le rapport de l'ONU,
M. Frison, n'intègre pas encore
l'impact de la guerr
parce que c'est tout récent,
est-ce qu'on se dirige
vers une crise
plus grave encore?
- Oui, mais il ne faut pas
oublier que
uniquement la crise du COVID
qui a mené à l'augmentation de
la faim
depuis 2015, on voit une
augmentation du nombre de
person
alimentaire. Et donc le COVID
a évidemment été responsable
d'un
significative. Et la guerre
en Ukraine risque d'exacerber
une indication qu'il faut
vraiment repenser les systèmes
trois crises des prix
alimentaires en quinze ans.
et puis en 2010, 2012, et puis
maintenant, en 2022 1021.
Or, on n'a pas tiré les leçons
on a continué sur la même lancée
de toujours centraliser plus
et aller vers des systèmes
alimentaires de plus en plus
mondialisés qui sont très
fragiles.
- Oui. En même temps, certains
diraient : ces grands systèmes
agroalimentaires permettent de
produire massivement, à moindre
coût, c'est un argument qui est
souvent avancé, qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça?
- En fait, le système que
j'appellerais un système de
production industrielle,
a montré sa fragilité également
et ses limites. On voit que
les zones de production
les plus intensives, que ce soit
aux États-Unis, au Ja
ou en France, les rendements
à l'hectare sont en train d'être
plafonnés, et même
malgré l'augmentation des
intrants qui sont utilisés
parce que le sys
durable. Ce sont des systèmes
basés sur des intrants externes
de fertilisa
et de pesticides qui détruisent
la santé des sols et
qui empê
fonctionnement de l'écosystème.
Et donc, il faut repenser
en pro
vers des systèmes diversifiés
et agroécologiques, c'est-à-dire
qui
fonctionne la nature avec
une très grande importance
dans le sol, mais surtout aussi
la diversité des espèces qui
qu'elles créent des synergies
entre elles pour avoir
résilient, notamment vis-à-vis
du climat et des changements
de plus en plus problématiques
aujourd'hui.
ça a été un plaisir de
vous parler. On va suivre,
- Merci beaucoup.
C'est un plaisir